today's guest is really just a patented
individual
this man is a patented style
of creative and and i think if god could
have patented him he would
and uh and so i'm just so happy to hear
i'm so happy to have him here today he's
already making me laugh and he's not
even here
yet um but uh he has so many great
characters
you have to check out his youtube
channel we will put it below
as the first link uh for you to please
go and check out
um you know him from his uh fresh prince
of dc
uh on youtube his craigs news live from
the trying to sing the song currency um
you know from his impersonations of the
jenners
and the daddy mama and whoever i can't
remember
caleb jenner and um all of those people
and what i'm telling you are the
kardashians what i'm telling you today
is we have mr
kyle donegan
sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
yeah we probably have similar kind of
maybe genetic hair products yeah well
you're from uh i think from the same
type of uh
community from louisiana no i mean old
country
community like uh oh yeah uh
english area italian
is this you we have polish nicaraguan
but really
yeah okay it's different somebody [ __ ]
on a boat probably
to get me yeah yeah yeah that's not
really a land animal but
um it's a strong um mix though
yeah i don't know if it's good hey kyle
can i have you pull the mic a little bit
closer
yes we do we kind of do a soft start
we're rolling so
yeah and well i like to soft open
yeah mm-hmm you relate
i'm a never late by the way are you
really yes like i
am upset i'm late and i when when i was
younger my mother was
was like the bus is coming
up screaming every morning we never were
late but
i have it in me if i'm going was it
really coming
yeah eventually but we never were late
right you know what i mean like she was
we'd have 40 minutes and she'd screamed
this that the bus yeah
because when the bus would when it left
she would have to drive
us this way but she never did because
she was
a panicked person and you were out there
now did your mother have extreme
was she like one of those extreme
panicky people yeah her anxiety is
through the roof and
it's really affected me to be honest
with you if we're gonna get honest on
this podcast
did your mother breastfeed you no
everything wrong
also as a cesarean which makes you a
social wreath
oh sociopath yeah oh you came out the
belly uh-huh
uh-huh my friend was breech birth out
the belly i'm like how do you even do
that
no i don't think that's that's the thing
oh he did it no but i don't think
you get breached birthed out you're a
breech birth
and then you get out the belly kid allen
did it yeah they said it i mean
everybody knew it his mom everybody just
kept saying it
and nobody ever said it about anybody
else so i would imagine you did it and
he seemed like the guy that did it dude
i didn't get oxygen for for a long time
and i came up purple and they put me in
a um
incubator and the doctors prepared my
parents that this one may not
you know be mentally well and i have a
theory i think
i i think i was born i think i was like
a genius
and then i got a little [ __ ] and now
i seem
like average intelligence yeah i mean
like gene
tarted exactly i like that exactly yeah
man i could see that in you man because
you definitely really
i could see you there's some doctor
walking over to your parents with like a
shoe empty shoe box
you're like hey you might want to put
some hay in this thing you know yeah
he's gonna like that
yeah and i didn't show bad signs when i
was younger like i would
just fly a kite for hours and just with
my tongue out
and i i was very focused on things oh
um i think i i probably was asked burger
or something no one tested you back then
they just were like he likes to stare at
kites or he likes to play with string or
whatever
right yeah yeah and i would just uh
like plank on the piano just for hours
like just listening to the uh
so little d flat the neighbors called
you
yeah yeah that's it yeah and then that's
wild so your mom was yelling for the bus
and what were you got who was in the
house
she still fills me with uh with a lot of
anxiety
everything everything is like she's
defusing a bomb like you have to put the
thing in
like that everything so i have a very uh
solid trigger to being late which i'm
sorry i'm late i don't like being late
and i was very anxious to hold right
over and i sped i sped past a cop that's
where i was
at mentally they don't care anymore
unless you are literally driving by
shooting people oh yeah the ca i feel
like they're not stopping
anyone i know i know cops my brother's a
cop busy really
and i mean the way this whole thing is
set up
how you gonna risk your your life and
your career
by you know he was telling a story some
some guy was like it was his
uh i shouldn't even say never mind
because it wasn't it was
they like someone's very illegal and
they just let him go they're just like i
can't
even right the black and white thing is
so intense it's like i gotta just not be
involved in this
oh if you're doing black crime you are
free to get yourself
it's yeah you can run into any you can
do any it's like
that's what it feels like because if
somebody records it then
they're suddenly you're the bad guy oh
yeah and they get like a certain amount
of
of the recording and then you're just
fired immediately but also
you these guys cops just defend cops for
five minutes oh totally
they imagine a job where you go where
people are being [ __ ]
all day like they're being [ __ ] over
here and you go there and they're
they're
they yell at you and they spit on you
yeah they're like okay that's finished
now there's these other people being
[ __ ] go over there yeah and that's
the
and then 20 years of that here's what
they what they need
not you know they need 20 minutes of
therapy
mandatory and uh oh we got a camera move
we used to be a peeping tom also we
don't talk about nick yeah he has like a
silent premature baby
is that right yeah me too yeah
oh yeah that brain but anyway this
should be a group there's got to be a
facebook group huh
adult yeah definitely i'm just wondering
about
the the effects of it and what they were
on man they gotta be heavy dude it's
like you ever take a cake out of the
oven like a few minutes early
and then the oven breaks and you can't
do any more bacon of it
yeah all the time and you guys have to
eat that kind of like crater cake you
know
although and that's that example i mean
cookie like fake
cake batter is like a flavor at um some
ice cream parlors you know it's
delicious even
uncooked yeah but it's just like humans
some people chocolate some people
vanilla some people uh
got the sprinkles in them gay men or
whatever you know the
fun fatty guy rum raisin yeah you know
paul newman loved rum raisin i worked at
this uh
haagen-dazs store in westport
connecticut he'd come in every now and
then
only guy who would get the rum raisin
wow you know paul newman kids don't even
know paul newman is anymore they think
he's that he they think he's a uh
condom or you know maybe yeah
it's a word but well anyway my childhood
was tracked my mother would film my room
with clowns that's another thing she did
to me well i wanted to
i want to know more about a little bit
of this birthing in the breastfeeding
specifically before we move on
because my mother had small breasts dude
and i remember i almost remember
trying to get milk out of it and there's
nothing in it there's no way you
remember that
i think i cuz sometimes i swear to god
kyle
sometimes i will kind of lay down and go
like this and it makes me
i almost feel like it's dinner time you
know like it's like
i almost remember being i know it sounds
crazy
it's not like a real memory like some
girl at a bar was like i remember being
eight months old like it's not like that
it's like a genetic
recon uh it's like a genetic it's like a
ghost in my body that comes to the
surface of my skin
when i do this like a ghost that has an
idea
that happened a long time ago what how
old were you when you stopped maybe
that's uh
when i stopped breastfeeding yeah maybe
you were 11.
no no no i was younger than that i don't
remember
but i don't ever remember seeing my
mother's breasts
past four or five and i remember
you remember seeing them yeah you can in
your mind imagine what your mother's
nipples look like and know what they are
i wouldn't say know what they are i
remembered them i think as a
feeding domicile kind of thing but do
you remember what your mother's nipples
look like
i don't ever really ever saw them i
never saw my mouth nipples
no even as you got a little older
especially
oh kyle your mother would be uh
nude around the house i saw my friend's
mom's boobs a lot
my friend's mom would just walk in buck
naked and and i
like there was 13 when you're really
interested you know
dude my friend scott's mom walking down
the hall in front of me one time
dropped something or the lord took it
out of her hand and said it on the
ground
for you yeah bro she bent over to pick
it up and had
no underpants on oh my god and i was
like i'm coming over here again
and that's when they didn't clean things
up down there oh it was oh
it was definitely it was just like you
prefer that now because
the first time you get sexualized you
usually are into that
like certain people who you know were in
defeat like they saw
feet when they first got sexually awoken
or they um
you know had someone we we know somebody
who like their one of the first
experiences was a girl told
him to masturbate in front of her a girl
told him
yeah and that was like his first sexual
first sexual experience
locks in your brain i know and then for
the rest of your life you're chasing
that dragon
so did you have that with do you now
like it
um that not not groomed
oh no i i i i will say this
the first time i ever masturbated was on
a shelving unit
because i climbed up this shelving unit
my brother had some magazines up there
crack them open they had a can of uh
mint julep liquor yeah and uh
cracked that thing open too and so i'm
sitting on this shelving unit dude on
the top
wait i'm sorry like that like like a
shelf like that
that's a shelving unit it was metal
though it was like one of the metal ones
with the cross with those cross straps
in the back going up the x's kind of
there's a metal and you were up on it oh
yeah and you're on the top 13 or 12
yeah i was probably about 11 or 12. and
i got that nudie mag i think it was
called
like bust or odor or something like a
french one
swank and i got yeah something like that
swank
uh rub or something you know just
something like
i don't think rub is one i'm sure it's
one i don't think
if not working with it dude it'll be
premature babies
yes that was kind of it wait that would
make so much noise and not be at all
stable for you
to uh oh that's part i think that's what
goes into it for me honestly why did you
just take the magazine down and go
somewhere else i mean that's so
that was our question because it was in
my brother's closet
so it was already like the most remote
place i could be for
parents or anybody could you come down
for a minute why did you be at the top
of the master
because that's where i got it and i
think i was just so in that i was there
does that image do a little something
when you see it
that's what i was gonna say when i'm
gonna buy a [ __ ] if i'm by like an old
like a
i don't want to say a poor shelving unit
but like the poor kids had them it was
the style that poor people had i can't
so when you're in like a marshalls you
might come across that and things and i
really do it like makes me want to climb
back up there like almost my arms will
start going like that
uh-huh but i remember ejaculating up
there for the first time
yeah you never forget that
oh i was i couldn't believe it
i was like where where what it is a
moment where you you're
you don't even know what happened uh
it's like
what's going on you think you're gonna
die you don't know what's gonna happen
you don't know if you're about to win
something yeah
and it's coming from like i mean it's
your like genetic
like it's like the dinosaur in you yeah
you know it's like that dirty reptile
it's like here's some billion year old i
mean you see uh
it's in all of us uh all animals and
also with the breastfeeding
i saw this monkey they reunite with its
mom you know after whatever
and i just knew to find her nipple and
it's just all
genetically coated in us that's why i
think we're very much
much more machines than we think um the
free will
uh and that's who we are a lot of it
we're on a uh
some sort of code don't you feel like
we're sort of
your behavior is a lot of it like that
exactly is coded in and i think there's
a lot more stuff we would think about
so do you think we have a lot of free
will no i i don't
i actually sam harris has a book about
it and he totally right he does not
believe there is
and i it freaks you out here's why also
i think you need to put a lot of um
weight into what he's saying is because
you don't want to believe it it's like
heaven a lot of people believe in heaven
yeah
because you want to believe it when
there's so much evidence there isn't
heaven
well i wouldn't say that well what about
this
okay the idea highway to it there
oh nice that was a great movie dude it
was
it yeah that show was great but but
listen if you got uh let's see at
amnesia
okay okay a little blood gets taken away
from your brain for a bit i believe it
and now you can't remember your family
or who you are all right are you telling
me you take all the blood out of your
brain you're dead you
suddenly remember everybody what is that
and they go oh that's the soul
where's your you know the soul when
you're alive wait what happens i don't
have any blood
yeah you have like if you're dead you
have no blood okay
i mean nothing's running through your
brain right when you had amnesia you
didn't remember anything how do you now
remember everybody and yourself
how is that possible what's your dad you
mean like when you go to heaven you
remember your family
yeah and you're like yeah you don't
exactly but most people believe in
heaven because they want to believe it
which is getting back to free will most
people
including myself and i had to put the
book down because it's disturbing
because he puts a very good case
together about how we don't have free
will and it's a white guy
it is a white guy unfortunately it's a
white guy no i still believe i look i
believe honestly mostly white guys
if i'm real honest with myself yeah and
like i mean i believe other people as
well but
when i think about people that i believe
like
about a lot of stuff a lot of them are
white i believe like a cat
casual guy i i i just go by tells
you know touching the face if someone
touches their face when they talk to you
yeah especially on like a moment that's
important if you ask someone a point of
question
and they go no i didn't do that they lie
that's a lie
biggest hell is the touch face is it
really part of it's actually
um biological like you actually get
blood taken away from your face when you
lie you feel guilt or whatever
so it becomes a little itchy and you
kind of want to like no but it's also
just like you're trying to cover your
mouth a little bit
right trying to hide the truth because
you believe you're an honest person so
you're just like
it's like a cognitive dissonance you're
just you
you have a little brain flash also
there's microaggressions
yeah someone will make a quick
expression if you catch it
say and that's all in sam harris book no
this is other stuff
oh but so you so going back to free will
yes sometimes i i wonder if
and now we're so getting programmed by
stuff it's like
that our free will whatever little we
have it's almost like um
there's so many dog whistles out there
now yeah you know like just with the
internet
and just you know the advertising yeah
it's like it's so hard to
battle it yeah you're getting programmed
and you also your
your thoughts come from your
subconscious you know and then you think
you thought your thought but you didn't
it just kind of
popped into your head you notice it but
see now then
but then here's and you you're actually
a great case for this because you're
like a very
interesting guy man and so i
you're one of the few people in the
world that i see
where i'm like oh this guy has unique
thoughts and ideas
so it's interesting that you would kind
of
go with that because i feel like that
doesn't really define
you really do you think it does no i
think i'm just a product of
my mother screaming at me as we've
covered yeah
um things in my childhood where uh you
know there's some
underwear pulled up higher than it
needed to be in the back on men or women
on myself oh really by others or by
others
you know some little bullying and then
there was like were you bullyable
i was very tiny i was miniature for so
long and i really liked girls
you know you get that age where you want
to be being tall
is so important when you're in like
seventh grade dude there's nothing
crazier than some little guy that wants
to [ __ ] everyone
yeah you don't want to talk but i was
like oh here we go look at him
yeah look at that he's holding his dick
yeah
he's just yeah he's playing a big dick
but he's just pointing his dick at the
end
and it looks bigger because he's so tiny
oh yeah it's crazy
yeah and then i was voted class clown i
cried oh you cried
and they found out about it i i cried i
mean i didn't cry like whale cry but
like i was in the hall when i found my
and and um and i i just started tearing
and they changed it to best
personalities they felt back me i
the idea of being a clown to me first of
all i was never
i wasn't trying to be a clown i was
trying to be cool pull up a clown nick
please cause he couldn't go on a shelf
but yeah i didn't even interrupt you man
but you were trying to be cool
now what methods were you using to be
cool you know like
hair combing gels um
yeah okay and then this i get into this
psychology so i get
voted class clown my i my mother knows
what i said about it and she starts
filling my room with clowns
and i'm i'm why why
why i don't know
but i i was so beaten down with like
my voice didn't matter when i was
younger that i never said i don't like
this
i just sat in my room with clowns just
for years and my phone would ring it
would just be this like laughing clown
what they go like hahaha that's
hysterical no way and that's my phone
and i'd be like hello oh my god
i didn't like oh my god years later i i
went to therapy i'm like why'd you
why'd you do that you were like well was
it
sounds almost willy like a very cheap
willy wonka kind of going
i just can't believe you had the clown
phone that was big
it was like a clown that was sitting it
was like this kind of it was sitting on
the thing
and its eyes would light up all the
creepiest thing you can imagine and it
would laugh
and i would just pick it up and talk to
my one friend
look i'm making this sound bad i i had
great parents and i had a great
childhood but there were certain moments
where you know
but what do you think it did to you is
that the phone
yes that's it that's so funny can you
play a video of it laughing and
bozo the clown phone yeah please do it i
want to see him get erect oh my god
you know how you were getting hard by
that countertop this is making a moving
unit this hit me in the gut right here
when i saw that clown
it made me nauseous here we go
[Music]
oh my gosh and that's your because
that's hysterical
it's kind of a cool phone like look
remember bozo the clown that show
vaguely one of my friends was on and i
think or somebody told me they weren't i
just
always thought they were i knew a clown
you ever made a real clown
and get to know him as a person oh no
yeah i knew a clown he was in a show i
did this like
did you do a lot of stage shows like i
started off as like an actor thing
i didn't honestly this is another thing
like my mother pushed me i never wanted
to get on stage or anything i was pushed
to audition
oh yeah and what about you i make her
sound horrible she's actually very
uh my my older brother and sister both
were like not performers
and i think i was the last one she's
like this one's gonna do this and then i
was on a movie
and uh we had a nanny for a week my
parents went to like australia
and she's like do you not want to be
here and i was like
no i don't she's like okay let's go home
it's the first time an adult like
listened to
oh i felt i'm exaggerating by the way no
look because i mean
you remember moments and like my parents
did an amazing job but there's like
moments that i remember
yeah and then i uh yeah i just got back
from this therapy this trauma center for
like a week and you talk
about all like your like growing up
stuff and like the things that
shape you why you behave the way you do
now yeah and you
fascinated me because you can't
there's moments that are so impactful
that that right on the slate of your
personality when you're younger you
can't
protect a kid enough even if you're the
best parent he walks out and
right somebody throws a [ __ ] little
harpoon or something at him and scares
him
a dog bites him yeah and you didn't do
the right thing after
yeah and then the there's one girl
someone's the teacher said to her uh
you're perfect and then she became
anorexic she remember that moment i have
to be perfect that's my identity
you can't help but like um run into
traps
yeah i don't think that's what i that's
one thing i was realizing after that
week at this place i'm like is there any
way to do it right no there's so many
variables you run into so many in one
day think about how many little things
happen to you
and then when you're younger you're just
so absorbing it and you're trying to
find out what's my identity who am i
and so those are really key and if you
get a dirty clue from someone a red
herring
yeah you know experiment in the 70s when
they said all the brown
eyed kids are dumber than the blue-eyed
kids
blue-eyed kids are smarter they've never
done this experiment now yeah it's a
famous experiment
and then the blue-eyed kids started to
do better in in on the test the brownie
kids started to do crappy and it just
this insidious thing seeps into your
head if you don't uh
but as a parent your job you can't
control
it do your best best personality they
changed it was it a small school yeah
like 150 kids in her class that's a
pretty decent amount
and i wasn't telling anybody were you
dating in high school what was it i
tried
and i was like the friend they would
tell like i [ __ ] this guy
i [ __ ] up last night yeah i love this
girl who who
loved my friend who was like freaking
like trash and i was that guy like
who's that guy john cryer i was just
john cryer all the time
oh yeah remember that pretty and pink
uh-uh that movie he just like he cried
off he played ducky you don't remember
that he played ducky in that movie
here he is here he is ducky that was me
the worst person to be in john cryer
from television
two and a half men two and a half months
there you go east town
i met um what's her uh molly wingreal
did podcast i used to do
and uh she came on it yeah and she she
was cool
she hates 80s music which i found
fascinating because she sort of made
that
kind of popular she's in the videos or
she certainly gets packed into it
i know you think she it's weird how you
kind of hate the things from your past i
feel like
i think you don't experience them the
way other people did
is that you think i don't know well i
don't know like
charles in charge guy hates charles in
charge you know
really scott bio i bet small wonder
still likes it was a small wonder
with that oh is that the robot girl is
that with uh jerry o'connell
you might want to check this out no this
you small wonder was the most amazing tv
show they ever made on the air
it was a man who was a robot engineer
and it's the worst acting in writing
you've ever seen like
the wife's like but you're a robot
engineer like she tells him what his job
is
to tell the audience with you so then he
has he made this robot that his boss
didn't like
a robot that would be make everyone a
kajillionaire and so he takes it home
and he works on it at home and then
she becomes part of the family and
here's a scene from it
isn't he cute my name is she's a robot
my name is vicky pleased to meet you
that kid never worked together none of
them worked again
the kid got molested probably his next
credit
sadly and that's joe biden right there
about to smell that lady
look at him grab her all aggressive
early 80s style
dude is it you know i mean you do so
many great characters man
uh are you starting to feel like
um well first of all i says do you think
that the ba
do you think biden has a that perv
streak in him
i don't i i i sometimes i wonder am i
just watching
enough weird edits of [ __ ] or is this
obvious i think he's um just
from he's a very touchy guy but i don't
think it's a perv
i'm gonna do some sexually solu i think
because he does it to like all different
types like
kids old men i mean he's like sniffing
old men's hair and he's touching
everybody he's touching
women more obviously but like i think
he's just
i think he's just a touchy guy my
opinion you got shades on them
no no i got i don't know i have [ __ ]
that's one yeah cool
i'll take mine off if you want no i want
to put mine on are yours pretty
expensive
yeah oh wow those are good
were you devastated was there a time in
your career where you got devastated out
here where you're like i'm not gonna be
anything
um yeah like this morning
[Laughter]
no i never felt like i made it i always
felt like i was
you ever see cliffhanger just like hang
white knuckling my career yeah
at all times i mean i when i look back
i i got to save at the last minute every
time every stage
i mean i started off doing um you know
sketch and improv it was
what i'm like like more suited to than
stand up
and then i'm like 25 like i have no
money and i'm like oh
there's no money in this it took me like
all that time to go there's no money
doing
sketch yeah no one said don't do that
yeah
you know where's the money in that yeah
like you should get
snl if i some miracle but like other
than that
so then i was like okay i'll do stand up
so i did that i got really lucky to make
a living doing that i felt like you know
this
owner of this club took me under his
wing because it wasn't a very uh
assertive
person yeah it's interesting i would
wonder how you would kind of yeah what
was your beginning stand up was it kind
of like brett weinbach kind of
you know what i'm talking about yeah i
love brett weinbach oh he's so funny man
yeah i'm just trying to wonder what
because i don't um
these are too dark are they they're too
dark no you put yours on yours are
lighter you can
see i can't see too much yeah brett
weinberg i i really started here earlier
and i had bad
i had i had bad management uh when i was
younger and not that they were trying to
do
a good you know but see
i would go up and i would do like a
guitar song and then i would do a
character it was weird
and back you know when i started it was
like you know tim allen whatever you got
a deal by talking about yourself
and so they're like don't do the guitar
don't do the characters
so i listen to them because i just
listen to what everybody tells me
and then i got to a point where now
luckily with like
the internet and the instagram and stuff
i can do
i'm finally doing what i should have
been doing the whole time yeah but i was
just
adults were telling me you know
successful managers and so i
thought that they knew best and yeah
i didn't have that inner thing where i
listened to uh
i'm i'm starting to do it now a little
bit more yeah
yeah man i mean i feel like you're
coming in your own at like a lightning
speed
um with craigs news live craigslist live
is
interesting because some people hate it
like it gets a
real response some people watch it
because they hate it i think you know
it's got like i would say 90 of the
people who follow me
hate it and wish i'd stop and there's 10
that are mad that i don't do it
more you know i do it like once a month
now and no one's happy by the way with
anything i put out
because i put up like i put this like
where's catty daddy or
or something else like where and then
and i so i just cycle around and you
know with making money in the internet
you got to be consistent every week
and i can't be consistent so now what
i'm trying to do is do like a weekly
show or
i do a little bit of everything which is
which is i don't know if i can
handle that much of a workload of trying
to write and shoot and edit i also have
to edit
you know i'm not a fast editor it feels
like a lot of work but
it feels like so what i love is that
it's so like you can tell that you're
on every every twist and moment of it
is associated to you you know so it's so
specific
um yeah man it's awesome to know that
you're like existing out there and
making cool stuff
i'm i'm i'm so people are excited that's
that's really nice because i i really
feel like it was like
hail mary pass uh this is happening and
youtube
i instagram i don't make any money i'm
trying to get everyone over to youtube
now i'm not getting on instagram either
yeah i just i'm trying to shovel
everyone to youtube and like that's
where
where
you can make something there they're
getting there yeah and i finally got an
advertiser yesterday which is really it
was like because i wasn't making any
money and
working like you know 10 hours a day
but um yeah eforms
oh i've used eforms before yeah they uh
came through
and they're they're sponsoring the fresh
present dc show they're like the
advertiser on that great dude yeah i saw
the first episode uh how was the
response to that
really good it's been really good and
i'm trying to detail it like
so i cannot it's not uh biden every week
and i'll start adding other characters
like i'm gonna have you know caitlyn
come in
other um and even like i did this time
canceler
uh sketch that people asked for i only
did one of them
but uh i'm gonna have my other sketch
other characters come into the show and
make it like a more general show not
just always about buying because i think
that would get old you know
yeah that's a good point that's a good
read man yeah um
what i've done the craig dude i was on a
date actually recently and i
may have tried to make love to this
woman or not and i kept doing the uh
craigslist live voice and
she hates me now i could not no it was
good i don't think it was meant to be
dude but
it's a good litmus test oh it was so
much fun though i couldn't stop doing it
which part was like
and i was like yeah i'm not even i can't
even get hard
look at death's penis you're talking
about your dick
yeah i don't see why that wouldn't be
sexually sexy kids are being so bad in
here
you know doing stuff like that like for
some reason every time i make out with a
girl i'll always be like oh these kids
are being so bad
i always say that for some reason like
these kids are being so bad in me
oh cranky is live i think and she's like
why do you keep saying greg's news alive
but i can't i couldn't not say it that's
so funny film that next time you do that
for me
put it we'll put on craigs news live you
know you like people
yeah just be if you do this i'll i'll
put you on the show it'll start people
other people doing it if we can get
everyone doing that when they start
making out
i love that moment when you first make
out with a girl i love hearing the
stories about it because
it's so awkward you're invading
like their space so and some girls you
know when you're younger when you know
it was like
i used to ask and they're like don't ask
and now it's like you better ask
yeah so it's like all weird nothing's
that clear and uh
i'll tell you this if anyone's curious
on how to like make that first move
yeah because some guys go in too early
whatever some guys don't know anyway
you've got to go by by touching like a
leg first
then if she touches you back then you go
to the next thing
you wait for her to respond you have
this
little physical dance first you don't go
in for a kiss
just out of nowhere or it's the end of
the night i'm gonna just reach in
hang back let a knight go by they didn't
make a move
she'll think you're cool i knew this
girl who um
was so i was fascinated with how she got
girls she was lesbians she got girls to
like her
and straight girls she would convert
them and this
i think works in la more than other
places but like scientology baby
absolutely this one time we're at this
charlie sheen roast
fun fact you're right you wrote on it no
i just add it oh
i was uh someone invited me so i was
sitting at this table with her and this
pretty like girl sits down and i could
see she clocked
my friend as like oh she's gonna want me
and then wait one of the pretty girl
sits down yeah and she's like clocks
like a lesbian
oh okay this is just just an example of
like right
so she the lesbian girl turns her back
her turns
fully takes her chance and puts her back
to this girl
so now this girl sits up like how'd this
happen
now she needs approval from this girl so
then the pretty girl goes
i'm gonna arrest him can you watch my
purse
and she goes no like that
what they dated they dated for two years
oh anyway just a little fun fact for
everybody
yeah and i'd be like yeah put your purse
in my heart a whole lot yeah that's what
i would do
okay whatever you want why don't you
just pour all your lipsticks down my
throat
i'll regurgitate them yeah it's like you
feel like you want to please but it's
it's also not being mean there's books
on this i'm not a knight yeah that guy
wrote it that i've read i read those
books how to nag a woman they used to
call it nagging
yes that book was called david or the
game
the game game or whatever what happened
to him
obviously the guy disappeared i don't
want to guess
yeah i mean is he married now yeah let's
see if he's married
if we could see a clip of i don't want
to no that's fine
waste anyone's time here but it does
kind of work
i i i i think you you really um
you know strauss lil strauss
yeah he looks really different
astronaut's name too neil strauss it
sounds like
a very good astronaut name oh you want
us to make out some more
i have my my whole thing if i look back
the women
in my life has been like they they um
i'm not very aggressive this is my point
really you had spade went on like kind
of a double date one night didn't you
yeah yeah he just mentioned it he said
oh yeah yeah
he's like he's like got done again out
of his house you know
we got a couple of or snappers were
taken out yeah
they're sometimes they're like these
uh i don't wanna talk [ __ ] about them
but like it's funny like
how you know because one girl was a girl
he was kind of dating or something and
then when the girl was her friend or
something
yeah i'm not we're not i'm not talking
bad about i'm just and i wouldn't have
to talk about it no i'm trying to
navigate i don't if this girl's watching
i don't want to insult her
oh she but she was sweet sad men
watching but she was sweet but she just
like
didn't know a generational disconnect
uh it was it was more than that like
this is an example
you know like me and me and david pretty
square and uh she's like oh
my friend this was like this was like
three girls without some this might have
been a different thing than he was
talking about but like she's like
she went in the um bathroom they went to
bathroom to do cocaine to the girls
oh there's like a nice restaurant they
went to cocaine and david goes oh they
can do it on the table and she goes oh
they can't okay she went to
get up and go tell them they could do
cocaine on the table like they didn't
get
jokes right you know like in a way that
blows your mind
the other thing they were german or
something might have been german
but that's interesting yeah um
dude i'm still thinking about the clown
phone
no oh you know what i had the sports
illustrated flip open
football phone we got that thing
look that thing up dude it was horrible
it was such a piece of trash
getting getting but it was so huge when
i was young we saved the kool-aid points
and we got
my sister got the kool-aid jacket and
then all the black dudes
oh you i always wondered who was
able to save all those kool-aid points
we did
is that your phone yep that football
yeah that is cool we thought it was cool
dude well we had very different phones
it fell off yeah yeah we did man we had
different phones one of the most
impossible things ever
everything i get and he always wants to
return the stores are busy
the cashiers are impatient this does it
busy it's just about the only thing that
wrecks the holiday season catch this
it sports illustrated everybody in that
video looked trans
it's a telephone my goodness it's a
telephone inside of a
man football inside of a football
it's in my mind
[Music]
the problem was it would fall off the
stand it comes on her actually
that is a cool idea nfl stand it would
fall
off and hang open and then it would be
i'll tell you
yeah that i just i kind of feel it
fumbled itself kind of
all right i want to let you guys know i
got some tickets coming at you
uh i will be um running my
netflix special taping over there in
nashville
uh and that is august 13th and 14th
those will go on sale next
friday also on sale now huntsville
alabama
we're just going to be practicing some
of that material for it
and that's huntsville alabama august 8th
9th and 10th one show each night those
are on sale right now
also still on sale we've got uh oh st
louis is sold out we've got cincinnati
charlotte
uh durham chattanooga knoxville
wilmington uh delaware wilkes
wilkes-barre
minneapolis charleston richmond virginia
baltimore portland burlington
vermont uh portland maine that was
albani new york
buffalo and columbus ohio get all your
tickets through theovonne.com
tour any other site there's going to be
up charges it's going to be
uh scammers and hype beasts
so get them there theovon.com tour
the new dates uh are for theo von
live and the huntsville and nashville
are for uh the dark arts finale so
looking forward to seeing you guys
everywhere thank you for supporting
uh me you know after years of
dealing with fine print contracts and
that's something a lot of people don't
have to deal with but i have to deal
with them
i realize i've been getting ripped off
by big business
and big wireless specifically
so when i first heard of mint mobile i
said what's going on here
are these people dandy are they not and
i realize they
are mint mobile secret sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online
only by cutting out the retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs
and the savings go on to you the
consumer
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month
unlimited talk and text and high speed
data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g networks if you're
not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service just 15 bucks a month
to get your new plan for 15 bucks a
month and then get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile.com
theo that's mint mobile.com
t-h-e-o cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month
at mintmobile.com theo
you know the price of gold has been all
over the place you know you might get
your little gold doubloon or something a
gold
shipwreck a little poseidon
[Music]
trident lurcher but acre
gold let you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as thirty dollars a month
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they discreetly
ship you acre gold to your house
and just recently acres introduced a new
hundred dollar a month
subscription to a five gram gold bar
acre ships your gold directly and
discretely acre designs their gold in
california and sources their gold from
one of the largest
mints in switzerland but the big
takeaway here is you don't have to come
out of pocket all at once
incremental payments for acre gold
visit getacregold.com theo
and start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
yup like willy wonka to qualify for the
giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient
and mentions at acre underscore gold
again that's getacregold.com theo thank
you acre gold
for supporting the show stay gold pony
boys
dude i'm still i'm still fascinated on
that moment of being young
and going in for that kiss i know i
remember i was at a fire
and uh the first time you went in for a
kiss yeah
okay let's hear this these are
fascinating to me i was at a fire dude
somebody had burned down something in
our town right
how old i was probably
i would say probably 12.
and i biked over to this fire and this
girl's over there
and some big dude was like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] need to kiss right and we were
too young to even hear anything like
this
and i like was in love with this girl
and she was like oh my god what a
and i look i was not i was like
not a cool i was not a kid you would
kiss if you were a girl uh-huh
my friend was my friend scott he got all
the kisses and i would just be like oh
yeah and i [ __ ] didn't know what to
do i didn't even know how to do it so i
like you [ __ ] better kiss yeah yeah
and so i opened my mouth and just like
started moving towards her face
and she like let me get like right onto
her face and i didn't know what to do
and it was just
so uncomfortable you just mushed your
like mouth on her mouth you just pushed
it
i just like
yeah was it good did you like it
it was scary i was my all i cared about
was hoping she cared
like okay i was hoping it was okay like
is this okay for her
and then like she never really even
looked at me after that and she played
volleyball and then
her name was emily and uh a couple years
later she let me brush her hair at a
campfire so i'm like i wonder if fire
has something to do with oh
she linked it up but she had beautiful
hair like a horse dude and she would let
me shield me brush it in a fire nice
mane and then she went
banging some dude in the woods or
something yeah right at least i got her
like
prepped up you got her yeah prime i was
like hey get out there give him hell you
know
i had my first uh kiss was this girl
she was like 13 i was like seven oh
god listen
i'm with like her friends and she was
like dating whatever your 13 year date
and whatever some guy and like we were
all the hampton beach in new hampshire
and sit around and she's like why don't
you take me on a date and they're all
laughing like she just kept saying this
stuff to me and they're like yeah take
her to mcdonald's i was like i don't
know i don't know
then everyone went inside and i was
standing on the step i remember so it
became her height
and she came up she came up to me and
said see you later and then she just
like
made out with me and then she was in her
bikini she turned around so like
it was i was i guess i was sexually
assaulted
but it was great it was like not you
know sex was bad but like
that was not a bad moment that is a good
memory that i have of being
um uh that's that's inappropriate of her
i guess but she's 13 that's pretty young
but still that's i was like seven that's
great
it was great then the next time was i it
was like remember truth or dare it was a
big
way you got a kiss first kiss and they
were like
french kiss whatever i didn't know what
french kiss was but i i knew it was like
something with the neck
that's what i thought so i was like i
think you i think you lick their neck
but i was like 60 sure yeah yeah
so they were like kyle french kiss
tiffany
and then tiffany gets up and i go to my
friend who said like the things to
french because
hey i don't feel like french kissing
right now can i just kiss her in regular
and he was like okay regular but
i just dodged a book i would have licked
her neck oh yeah
i would have just like looked
like a couple llamas saying goodbye to
each other yeah
exactly yeah oh man
it's so crazy how there's so much going
on inside of you in those
moments it's so intense in the rest of
your life i'm just sort of like
living off i remember the first time i
saw a boob in the moonlight it was the
first time i saw a live
boob oh god and like i still remember it
like you remember your mom's i guess was
your first
boob yeah wait we never talked about
your mom's nipples
you don't remember exactly i have a
decent memory of them
are they big areolas are they no small
yeah can we confirm that i don't want to
call your mom and confirm that
i love my mom i don't want her to i
don't want it i mean i know oh could we
uh it would be it would be she wouldn't
tell her
do you want to draw him huh you want to
draw him so you draw him and then you
send her you could
see it just right hey mommy that's right
yeah
dude i saw my grandmother's breasts she
was changing shirts one time
even though she wore only the same shirt
all the time
i think she just went and changed like a
fresh one
and uh i walked by the room and her door
was open and she was just sitting on her
bed and her breast right and she saw me
see him
and she hated me for it she didn't go oh
honey him
no that just glared like something was
wrong with me yeah oh really
i met a guy last night a guy met a girl
on a date last night
he goes hey i really like your hair
right nice guy
because i really like your hair she goes
it's a wig
like it's his fault yeah like it's a
good wig then yeah she's like it's a wig
that's uh okay there's something going
on with her i like your [ __ ]
fake hair then who keeps your thing yeah
she's nicer
no that's she's got a lot going on oh
yeah
nothing weirder than a mean grandma
though that story's upsetting
i had one grandmother that was a little
she wasn't
here's this we were riding the car she
was smoking on the back and i was i was
as you know very quiet child i never
spoke up for myself
and i was about to vomit so i said to
her
nana do you mind not smoking i don't
feel well it was very hard for you to
say that wow
so she goes yeah popper she kept smoking
and i got off and i remember i
barfed on my flip-flops i can still see
the barf on my flip-flops oh
and she wasn't like oh i'm so sorry you
did tell me that and i'm sorry
she's like i gotta kind of clean off
your flip-flops yeah i loved her but she
didn't know it was a more and we're also
softer people i was a sensitive kid so
yeah things hit me like
really i like internalized everything
like i remember my grandparents we were
driving one time across
america or somewhere it had to be
america
yeah and um i think my gran
somebody accused me of pooping myself
and i didn't a grandparent yeah or
somebody said hey somebody pooped
themselves in the car
mm-hmm you know and i was the only one
in the car that wasn't a grandparent you
know
so i but i hadn't i kept like thinking
like you know you can feel like if
there's poop in your pants
yeah i couldn't feel that so i was like
i don't i didn't do it you know
and my grandpa had done it right he took
me to the gas station whatever though
went in the bathroom and like washed my
butt as if i'd done
it did he also wash his butt yeah
so he got back in the car and
he used you to cover his [ __ ] oh and my
grandma hated me for it
dude my grandma was nuts man she had
like this lady that would bring her pet
raccoons and i couldn't go
in there when they were in there pet
raccoons
yeah this lady named dell was her name
like the computers
oh [ __ ] well maybe your grandma's trying
to protect you from like a dangerous
animal
nah she just wanted to be together with
that lit she just wanted them to all to
herself
but it was just a different time man
yeah i think
generations are different too so it's
weird because i feel like our parents
probably didn't like
attach so many of their feelings to
their parents and stuff or their
behaviors to how they were raised
yeah it was different but now we kind of
do that a little bit you think back and
go why am i like this
yeah he was a lot shoving down in the
generation before us
now it's almost too much uh
saying how you feel about things i think
publicly i see so many videos and i
think
you could have kept that yourself yeah
yet or some stuff like that demi lovato
girl keeps coming out of the closet
every week as something new
yeah you know she's gay she's straight
she's a merry-go-round
she's a bartender one week there's a
video this girl online
she's and she's explaining how she
changes gender it could be on the hour
but it's like how how am i supposed to
know so she has bracelets she wears and
she's wearing this this the
means this it's like you got it it's
exhausting to be your friend i would
think yeah
miss man what about this yeah and it
also
well now it's come full circle because
you have transgender
you have men competing in women's
athletics that i
i'm sitting back and enjoying this show
because
it really through a monkey wrench people
don't know what because it's like you're
trying to support
and hate the same person and you're like
your mind explodes
and you got to feel bad imagine you're
you're a woman and you are
worked your whole life i'm going to the
olympics everyone's like you're the best
and you're the fat
and then this 43 year old guy comes into
this
he's yeah this is not gonna last there's
no way
this is dude there's a scene we're in a
unique time
you can't be biologically a man and and
join in
in a female olympic sport warren hubbard
has become the first ever transgender
athlete
and is she packing rude or what's her
deal
do they say they why don't they just
make a section for transgender people
yeah maybe that's the answer i think
that's the answer
make and don't even make it all the
olympics at first just make it like a
just a
national chat you know what i'm saying
like see if there's enough to even make
a competition you might only have
there's not gonna be enough of an
audience they probably know that the
financials don't work out
i'm sure triller would sponsor it dude
the people that did that
god they're making money i don't know if
they are dude it looked like a place for
that
uh they had too many concerts in it and
stuff i don't know did he make
20 million off that thinking of
something else those fights one of those
kids did
wow we gotta do what if we fought what
could we make
if we you're i think 20. we take our
audiences we say
we're going to fight and we're it's
going to be all out like we're we don't
want to fight that's what's
fascinating oh that's a good i we're
going to get in the ring
we don't want to fight and we're going
to but we're going to
yeah someone falls down for real and
hurt well fall yeah but that's called
knocking somebody out yeah so someone's
knocked out we fight there's no bell
there's no there's no ref it's just us
oh no ref yeah i like that
what would we make i think 20 hit 20k
each
that's not worth it if you said
a half a million dollars we'd have to do
it wouldn't we
is that a half mill i think you would
have to fight
what would be let's do a comedian match
up and maybe we could put this card
together okay for people
and maybe we don't even fight we're the
announcers boom
now we're making money we're still
making our 20 but we're not crying we'll
get yeah
yeah yeah who could we put together i
think you have to put
chris julia he's in the first he's he's
the uh
main card yeah he's on the main card we
have like eliza slashing during like the
lower card i got chris versus eliza oh
my god she would destroy
he would destroy her i mean she would
not i don't know she's got pretty
jacked arms i don't know she would
probably take the women's
uh uh whitney maybe whitney versus eliza
would be
quite a match-up both both like athletic
whitney's got them heat bags i want her
dog them tits
would that help the fight or i don't
know it would help me why
elijah that uh load it up no i don't
know
a lot sarah has that anger eliza's just
like toned from angry yeah yeah
yeah those are rage muscles oh dude
she's always mad
sarah teen will get destroyed i mean
absolutely
she's from georgia dude she would bite
the freaking
she'd snack the volvo off of somebody if
she had to if she would grapple well
that's a good point she gets them on the
ground and she's a child so she has
something to fight for yeah exactly that
gives you the double strength thing yeah
half these vacant ovaries have nothing
out there going any letterman would do
pretty well i think
he would do it well yeah she's tough
greg fitzsimmons was out
a lot of street fights when he was
younger greg i think i'd put him in
against a woman
that's what it is it's like it's greg
versus annie letterman yeah it's like
that this is the fight that people want
to see did you and annie date or no
we didn't date and like we didn't we
didn't know we didn't we weren't
boyfriend or girlfriend but we were hung
out for a little bit
and uh women end up just hating me so
that's
the pattern yeah do you think have you
been in a real relationship
yeah i've been in a bunch oh wow really
and what seems to be the thing is there
like an ending piece like
mine i have like big commitment issues
and then i'll like have some sexual
malfunction
as i get into relationships okay um
so i just don't get as like
exacerbated in my penis or anything if
i'm just like with the same partner you
know kind of yeah
yeah woman yeah but um so
i just you know so i that usually kind
of my relationships will fade out there
because i think i don't want to commit
so my body's saying is like
we're not gonna [ __ ] yeah there'll be
little clues along the way
where you go oh i shouldn't do this long
term i shouldn't have a baby with this
person
a lot of my relationships i look back
and i i imagine
like drawing it out in your head you're
like what does it like for a kid i
always do that
yeah and i imagine like in a room with
the baby going
mommy's not happy today sure we gotta be
quiet and then i go okay this is not one
listen to that song
in the arms yeah
mine is a drift where i don't think i
have it fixed i think my next
relationship will be um
like like a forever longer term thing
it's because i don't i i wasn't
expressing my
problems enough i squelched them back
the same patterns
and then it builds up like resentment or
something and there's like a drift and
then we kind of break up
that's usually what happens it might
yeah by past relationships
but are you a real hammer in the bedroom
or you want like a delicate man it's a
hammer time
really one yeah cannot even imagine that
things change when the lights go out
it's always that's the key that's the
thing
yeah like i know a famous musician that
people say is like a love maker and you
would never expect it like he lights
candles and stuff and it's like a dude
you'd be like
i don't do that but i and i think it's
key like when you're
you're younger yeah you listen and ask
what they like
and then you start to get uh like a
rolodex
of ideas and stuff yeah and just you
could feel out what
type likes what and then uh you know
but you know young guys don't ask you
know and in my year when i was young i
was so horny i would be like i would ask
anything like how are you doing and all
i would hear as soon as they were
talking was like
it was just like i couldn't hear and it
was just so it was hard to like pretend
you were hearing you know yeah
then it's like i mean you know could you
have a baby you think i could see you
holding a baby
i could see you escaping to canada with
a baby if things got bad here
yeah that's what i would do that's
exactly what i would do go to canada
yeah i i didn't think about having a kid
i mean yes
what's going on you guys um the thing
about uh
having a kid is nobody uh sells that
very well at all
i mean you hear them they go oh it's
changed your life it's a lot of work
it's just yeah it's not like it's great
it's never that
yeah be prepared if your relationship's
going to change with your woman it's not
going to be it's more of a true
partnership so you got to say goodbye to
the romance it just that's been
um so documented yeah do you want to
have kids
i think i need to get to a place where i
want to i'm starting to see you being a
good dad
better you should be a dad that'd be
good i think i would i just don't want
to be
i want to have i just can't imagine
something being at my house all the time
when i'm not there
that's it yeah
i i just not that i'm not there but just
the thing is it was never go and it
needs you all the time yeah
you never go it's like how did where
that yeah it's got too much batteries in
it mm-hmm
and if you stop it you go to jail here's
a guy right here who's doing well right
here my buddy
you know this is gary larson's son who
used to draw the caricatures
no [ __ ] he kind of looks like one of the
characters not really but that would be
cool though theo
kyle what's up guys hey i was just
wondering
how do i know if you're not a deep fake
oh [ __ ] gang gang this is gonna uh
this is gonna happen five years from now
that'll be a real
legit thing what what is it someone's
already fakes so a lot of it's like yeah
it's it's funny when i'm watching the
characters it's like
i when i'm watching your characters i
feel like i'm watching them
i know it's your creativity behind it
but i feel like i'm watching them most
of the time
you know it's funny i don't use the deep
fake technology that's really good
mine is a shitty janky thing because i
found
that the real deep fake is creepy and
not funny like
the wrong side of your brain is is
freaked out when it's
close to the person yeah like i don't
know if you've seen the
real deep fake ones that look really
good have you seen those
i think i've seen some of them i got one
of uh tom cruise
yeah like this
so that's my friend miles fisher dude is
that right
yeah he's killed you know reminds me
he was once in the russia he ran into
uh gorbachev look it's amazing
that's just him he looks like this but
they just
face on him he already does a good
impression himself oh okay but the
defensive
people he's fooled like a bunch of
people there's he's got a tick-tock
account that's like
good for him it's amazing but anyway
it's um
i find it's not as funny yeah comedy
doesn't work when your brain is like
wait something's wrong here
it's like the brain needs to know
something's wrong yeah just so he can
comfortable and relax like south park
looks really goofy
um and the face swap thing i have looks
very goofy it's quite like
kind of broken but that i did a common
essential pilot and we used this
extreme deep fake and it was like creepy
it was wow
it wasn't funny they didn't pick it up
huh no but
i'll tell you this it was crazy what i
made
what i did with their money was crazy it
was awesome no it was crazy
it was did you ever put it out i just
put like everything i do and
here's what i thought i was like i'm
gonna show them like i could lead a
sketch show because i
do music and these other things but then
i like i wrote this script
and then i thought uh it was like a
three part like
a b and c plot time jump script it's
always already confusing
yeah and then i'm like i'm gonna have
the commercials and show like my other
characters within that
but you can't jump away from the things
i learned you can't jump away from a
narrative story
and go somewhere else for any more than
like
10 seconds like right family guy will do
a quick joke but you got to come back to
the story i would go away for like a
minute minute and a half
so then it feels like you just turn the
channel on the person it doesn't work
even it's funny they're like why i was
watching that other thing then the time
jump and the three plots made it really
confusing
it was just so it just looked like you
were changing
channels it was crazy is it is it so
do you confuse yourself sometimes with
kind of trying to put it all
together is it yeah i'm still trying to
figure out how to do a weekly show where
i don't lose my mind where i'm
satisfying
people and i can have a regular show so
i can make
um a living doing this because right now
it's like
you know i do show like i started doing
this like sylvester stallone show which
was gaining
followers and stuff but then it's like
other people are like
there's too much of this so i stopped
doing it then that drops off and those
people like where's that
it's just like i gotta do one thing and
somehow do little clips of everything
i'm not sure and you were doing
craigslist live five four days a week i
was doing it
so much that was just like a for me it's
just trial by fire and just yeah i'll
get better if i just keep doing this
yeah and i was kind of feeling that way
about it you're gonna you're gonna it's
all gonna i mean it's happening i feel
like it's growing your channel is
growing
yeah it's growing and getting
advertisers i can get off the grid with
having to worry about a network and all
that stuff because what i do i don't
think is
easily advertised it's very um offensive
to a lot of people kind of or i don't
think it's just genuinely funny
or it's well i feel like it's not
offensive personally because i don't
want to hurt somebody's feelings
i i just know it it's it clicks all the
buttons of an advertiser says no we're
we
we're not gonna advertise right but
that's all gonna i feel like slowly
that's gonna change i mean in
five years every other person is going
to have a network
you know a small little network yeah you
can see it like
even with podcasts and it's like rogan
was this thing that
is like insurmountable you know and then
there will never be another rogan you
know there will just be other small
there'll be some big podcasts
yeah like jack shepard and like i mean
there'll be some big shows but
there will never be i don't think
there'll just be a bunch of other kind
of smaller tiered shows now
yeah and then there will be even
different ones you know and it'll like
it's all getting different you know yeah
yeah i think i think we're in the right
your pocket
you're in there you're in the future but
it's funny because youtube is now i
guess
like that they take so much money you
first had a podcast netflix hires first
had a podcast
netflix hires jerry eaton oh okay
i don't know if i would watch podcasts
on netflix though
i don't know i feel like they're just
getting into it because amazon's taking
over
all of a sudden that's the weird thing
though i it's weird that like
i don't know how they're gonna but who
knows who knows what will happen i love
youtube it's just
they take like percent of your super
chats
yeah thirty percent of your thirty
percent of
everything else like your members i have
members joining
and like they take that much of the
stuff yeah
that's unreal is only five to eight
percent
but it's harder it's harder to get
people from youtube that's the thing
it's like
the problem is like people don't want to
get off a platform like getting people
from
instagram over to my youtube has been
like a sludge it's been tough
and then getting them to like patreon
it's like another thing so i was like
let me just do it all on youtube but uh
yeah they take so much it's brutal it's
a lot
it's crazy man it's a and um and the
government takes
50 yeah like
california and the federal government
it's like 40 some percent and then
yeah it's pretty crazy it's crazy for
yeah california and
specifically for la it's an extra
percent so it's 14
living in california on top of it yeah
um kyle have you thought about doing uh
seasons
like maybe do ten episodes instead of
trying to do that every week do ten i
think that's the way to go
because then and i will give you credit
for that idea
here's a beautiful question from a guy
right here good man probably
guys leaving his family someone's like
to imagine what yeah it doesn't seem
like he
just left them and your work
been following you for a long time feel
you as well
you demand um yeah
guess these questions for kyle um how
have you felt in terms of you know
recent censorship and kind of
shadow banning i don't know i don't i
don't want to call it you know that
serious of a term but you know i'm sure
some of your videos and stuff like that
get kind of swept under the rug
sometimes based on the uh
the content and the people involved with
it so
not to get too serious but you know just
kind of want to know your feelings on
that
without getting too political and uh you
know see what you think about the
algorithms
that's going on on social media right
now that kind of favor certain things
and
you know kind of hide others so cheers
man keep it coming and a big fan of
y'all's work gang gang
he's in a honda civic i believe he could
be and it looked like it was a stick
shift as well did you pick that up at
all
the stick shift yeah i didn't clog that
but he also maybe
you might have a dog if i'm looking at
that back seat is it dog hair
no it's just a design um no that's a
good question
dude i look at this stuff he also shaves
his neck well
do you know what i mean that's not easy
he's got a clean that's a strong beard
oh so definitely i would eat out of that
neck you know what i'm saying
he moisturizes it yeah if he's back
clean or if he doesn't and he has blue
eyes
um yeah the question brother yeah that's
a good question that's a good question
and
i don't mean to be paranoid but when i
look at like like percentages and then
comments
because they don't ban those there's
definitely some squelching going on
because it's not tracking with other
videos you could tell
um by like percentage and um oh yeah
comments kind of how many views a video
gets
and the biden stuff has just been like
really squashed on
instagram in particular um
but yeah i mean it's crazy how much the
like the media influence i mean
just politic it's just crazy how much
it's gotten i stopped tagging i didn't
tag biden's time because my last video i
just didn't tag him
yeah um but yeah i don't think you need
to but it's it's crazy
i mean the power that they have too
because it's like that's our only way to
communicate now i know
but when there's money involved and i
don't think it's some dark
you know whatever people think i don't
think it's really a political thing i
think it's
money i think it's like advertisers want
to stay away from some political so
youtube gets that clue and so you're not
going to be not going to make much money
off of your video so we're going to but
if you do a trunk if you
had done a trump one i bet they would
push it oh maybe i don't
i think i don't i don't know the answer
but i think they don't like anything
political on uh youtube instagram
i don't know the answer but i definitely
uh that could be true
i don't i don't know either um but
luckily the thing we have is like uh
yeah but it's like anything it's not
like
anything that's ins like it definitely
all the mainstream media certainly skews
more leftist
yeah yeah totally i mean no cnn is the
most ridiculous channel
it's gotten so bad i used to be a cnn
watcher right yeah like five years ago
and now i'm like nothing this is just
anarchy
this isn't even real jeffrey toobin
apologizes on cnn just real quick
so funny have you seen this yeah i mean
this is the channel now that this guy
he and he says here he didn't know the
camera's on
the the conversation's over but they
need to
he needs to go to therapy to be a better
per better person yeah
but a person who knows how to work zoom
better yeah like she's like she acts
like she doesn't masturbate in this
i want to find the shorter one what the
hell were you thinking
yeah it's like it's just so bizarre
it's bizarre that's why and this is one
of the things that's helped create such
a better world for uh
hello allison it's been a while it has
been a while indeed
i feel like we should address um what's
happened
has the most i don't masturbate dress on
you oh
definitely i don't even have a vagina
in fact i uh look once a month
i cough a little bit of blood into a
napkin that's it
that is what she has maybe you want some
other nose runs
right just a drip see you since some of
our viewers
look both of his hands up on the
yeah table yeah i'll recap i'll do the
honors
and she's just help yourself okay help
yourself poor choice of work
on a zoom call with your colleagues from
the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time look at this
people were caught
masturbating on camera emasculated man
so you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you the assistant had been on leave
for example you have to do why
why would he how have you not done this
okay because it's already done
it's already as hilarious as it could be
that's a good point
um to quote jay leno what the hell
were you thinking well obviously uh i
wasn't thinking very well
drag him through the mud and say what a
bad person i am he just didn't know the
camera though
i think one point this is him saying i
wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
yes it is he didn't think i was on the
call that that's
your defense other people could say
that's a really good defense yeah and it
just
didn't think people could see it it's
like jerk in front of a window like oh i
didn't know someone could see me i mean
it's a little different because it was a
zoom call but
he he really should know the etiquette
of the with the lights on
i don't know what happened yeah he's at
that age where you don't know
i'm shocked i'm amazed the guy still
jerks off that was the most surprising
thing well that's what i was thinking
imagine the first time
he jerks off again after that and
looking at his dick like you saw
you got me into this but i'm still going
to come back like an abusive
husband you go back to that's when
you've really
lost the fight it's like that movie the
five parties or whatever kind of
what's up with me uh i don't think
that's right but it's almost like it
reminds me of like bobby
brown and tina turner or whatever yeah
yeah exactly
exactly when he went back to his penis
even though it got him into
a whole mess yeah he just slowly unzips
his pants and sees it
i'm gonna do it again yeah oh or i'm
gonna teach you
oh you think maybe that would be a that
would be a
i think a healthier thing to go at it
yeah
with that attitude little boy he's son
of a [ __ ] get a little bitty [ __ ]
yeah dog leash around you like the
camera on you turn the camera on again
you like that
all right next question spit donkey
stick
this guy but yeah that's insane like why
would you just say the guy had a natural
deal he forgot the zoom thing was on
it's like you can't laugh it off but the
weird thing is it's like the more
that we have to say things that are
we have to call out ridiculous because
the more that we don't the more it
becomes
that's the norm yeah ex really
that's a great point because there's
nothing left like the major
uh networks and outlets are acting like
this is normal and that he needs to
bow to the holy
people who who are the people that don't
right like who
everyone relates to him that's right
watching he's like oh man that would
suck
right who are the people like oh i can't
imagine how how'd this guy even do
what's going on yeah who's going like
i'm glad he apologized to me
is there anybody at home thank god
toobin apologized now i'll listen to his
thoughts right so then what are we
apologizing to
it makes no sense it's all a big show
it's silliness
and i mean luckily there is youtube and
stuff where we can make
people could talk and twitter people can
uh
but yeah people barely can though
twitter's i mean twitter yeah yeah it's
getting surprised twitter's bad
i mean you just get attacked you say
black twitter gets insane it's like
people that have
you what's black twitter it's just like
a big group it's just it's mostly black
people on twitter i guess this might
also be white twitter but they also
hashtag it a lot black twitter it's like
black twitter go get them you know
and it's like some lady named entendre
who has literally 230
000 tweets and it's like what how could
you
and it's just like tons of people like
that and it's just
it's just amazing how we let twitter run
everything like
you would think if something was this
bad for us if it caused
this much pain and panic in the world
um like i even had this this came up i
remember
comparing coronavirus to the what oh i
said this is right at the beginning of
coronavirus
i said coughing is the new n word
that's a good point though crushed bro
this
must have got a lot of tweet retweets oh
it was so great
people are happy to retweet um
yeah decent amount anyway a ton of life
that's a good point though you're right
people
really got upset if you coughed yeah
really upset
because i've done both dude and uh
definitely the cough
that is a brave tweet you did that was
the call that was a brave tweet
you know what's funny i got a text from
my agent i got a text from freaking like
a
bit like a guy who's an agent like some
of the biggest stars out there
who was like love that tweet today bro
like
there's so many people that are like
cheering on anything that's just
because it's like now it's the
punishment is so severe you are brave to
put that out it is a legit brave
uh thing to do because it's the
punishment is like
but look at a guy like morgan wallen is
a white musician right does country
music
his ticket sales quadrupled when he just
said the n word
[ __ ] calling his white friend that
right and not even like as like uh
you know he just said like you hear it
on rap music or whatever yeah um
so i think there's the way to use this
whole thing
and i'm not saying go out and yell the n
word or write it on a book
you made a comedy joke that's not you
want this now you
want people to can you believe he did
this you almost
want the canceling because it's only
going to help
yeah that's why i hope youtube is like i
just hope but that's the thing
that you can't control is if the
platforms will let you remain
yeah yeah i mean and it feels like game
of thrones almost
yeah i worry about my youtube channel
i'm concerned do you
go to nick for that nick's a good judge
do you think or not look at it nick
would you think
you would worry about kyle's youtube
channel i really don't cause like you
said like
it's it's only the p it's the appearance
of the money
they because you're talking about
political but the stuff you're making
fun of is like
has nothing to do with political beliefs
on either side well there's a lot of
stuff there that uh i mean
it's kaitlyn jenner there's caitlyn
jenner's stuff there's a big hilarious
there's a big crazy you see her drive
down the road the other day someone's
like go get him
joe or whatever they call her now and
she's like thanks buddy
yeah baby thanks
liquid death man if i had an extra
eighth day of the week
if i had saturday sunday
[Music]
grande maybe grundy or gang day
that'd be good if i had an extra day
what would i do i'd probably do arts and
crafts or teach it
teach arts and crafts to children
macaroni necklace and
you know construction paper glue
different items paint make a crown for
you
for your kid or for your daddy
if you're a business owner you probably
know exactly what you do with an extra
day of the week
maybe you launch a new website spend
more time on marketing your services
or find new more creative ways to build
your brand
well with fiverr all the freelancers you
could ever need are right at your
fingertips
fiverr connects businesses like yours
with freelancers offering hundreds of
digital services
that's right if you need somebody to
help you design something or
organize something you need a piece of a
new software an app anything
anything your business needs fiverr can
help
fiber fibers global network of on-demand
freelance talent is here
whether you're launching your first
business or scaling your current one
it's easy customize your search by
service
deadline price seller reviews and more
check out fiverr f-i-v-e-r-r
dot com and receive 10 off your first
order by using my code
theo that's right find all the digital
services you need in one place at
five e r r dot com code theo
again that's fiverr.com code
theo get your business to its best
you know some things are uh better at
home and one of those things i think is
eating pudding i don't
like eating pudding outdoors or out in
public i like to eat it privately
also sleeping i like to sleep at home in
my bed
some things are just better at home
sweet home and one of those things
is peloton peloton delivers a workout
experience that you'd
never imagine was possible right in your
own home
with peloton you'll have a workout
experience like no other
that's right from keeping up with close
friends to enjoying world-class workouts
with people around the globe
whatever your mood or overall fitness
goals are peloton can help
choose from cardio strength yoga
pilate outdoor runs
meditation and more peloton offers a
seamless
fit into your lifestyle when you
purchase the peloton bike
you get access to live classes and
thousands on demand
plus access to the app to get you moving
anytime
anywhere with a boot camp between nap
times
or a ride before brunch you can
seamlessly fit peloton into your life
that's right with the peloton bike
there's nothing like working out from
home
learn more at one peloton.com
new members can try peloton classes for
free for 30 days at
one peloton.com app terms apply
that's o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
get healthy uh yeah that um
dude in a year in two years you can have
your own studio
you're gonna be making half a million
dollars a year off of youtube
and you're gonna be in a great spot man
that is a dream to have your own thing
where you're not
because even just being an actor for all
those years just waiting for an audition
and then you go in there and then
they're like
all right you're like am i good enough
this is awful yeah
you wait around little biscuity freaking
chick that's never done yeah
and then you're doing someone else's
writing that you don't like that's
awesome can i please have this job
i did that forever i stopped going out
on auditions and stuff because
it's all the time it takes to memorize
and then we're driving to the thing
anyway
and then showing up unprepared that's
what i do all the time i drive over
there
so prepared one time i came back from
i remember this i came back from las
vegas somebody give me while i was there
a rock of cocaine i'm not even joking
i've never tried cocaine as big as this
little thing's head
yeah it was a full rock i was like he's
like you want some coke i was like yeah
i do
and i was like all right i'm gonna go in
the bathroom and he hands me literally
this thing was like
it was about two-thirds the size of a
baseball so i'm like it was a ch it was
a rock i couldn't i've never i've only
how do you gust so i didn't know i go in
the bathroom and i'm like trying to rub
it against my face
and uh that can't be oh dude that can't
be the way you do it
i couldn't even eat at the buffet the
next morning i [ __ ] couldn't get my
face
open but that day i had to fly home to
l.a right
you're just rubbing a rock on your face
yeah dude the whole way home
and i even dropped it on the bathroom
floor on accident
and it didn't break dude wow so it was
definitely i think it was cut with quick
crete
did you ever do it hold on so i get to
the audition i am
so jacked out of my brain for doing
cocaine for a few days
i go in there and i tell the lady right
yeah this character would be a lot
better
if the character had this cocaine
problem
she's like oh really
it had nothing to do with the script are
you high on cocaine at that moment
uh i was still heavily under the
influence i remember having all like
these little sores on my tongue that
happened from like uh oh my god just
like the cocaine songs will get on your
tongue then it kind of burns it jeez
and i was like you know what would be
great it was like a it was like this new
age snow white that they were doing i
was like
is it the guy snow yeah
so it's like disney is that a cocaine
coke head we going to disney show
out where they play all day
i've never tried cocaine this goes back
to like free will because the first time
i saw people do cocaine they were so
annoying to me that i just didn't do it
well you'll eat your neighbor's ass dude
but you won't want to talk to them
yeah they were like everyone's like but
they're everyone's like waiting to talk
next but
my car but my car yeah and it's horribly
up to 5am and you you'll [ __ ] get it
dude you will
swap email addresses with a dolphin when
you're on cocaine dude
everybody likes comes up with big ideas
and then nobody can even wake up for
three days yeah
nightmare i am so glad i am not on
cocaine today
i'm glad praise god a lot of beards in
the questions
yeah did i answer that guy's question
thank you what was his question uh
the censorship one yeah
do you worry about i guess you do if you
say i do i mean i feel like my
by my latest videos on youtube and
repressed a little bit on instagram too
the fresh prince of dc yeah it's just
it's not matching up the numbers and the
the other percentages it seems seems
like
very something's very suspicious about
the uh
and the amount of giant accounts that
have commented or interacted that should
like make it
really pop yeah and plus friends that i
that always
you know like things even though they
don't watch my thing they just like it
they just like whatever like friends of
mine they just never saw it they just
never saw it you know so it's like
i don't know well i know trump i think
has a lawsuit right he's trying to get
against these organizations
yeah maybe that'll be one awesome thing
that comes out of trump man
um is if he because it is
it is not it's weird when
something else has control it's control
if the one thing that's good about
youtube is people like
and and um make comments and like share
it that does
help the youtube i've noticed yeah it
doesn't help the instagram but
youtube it does a little bit big tick
big tech okay
three real nice terrific i'm so terrific
today in conjunction with the america
first
policy institute i'm filing as the
lead class representative where is he
looks like he's at the white house
i built another white house the big tech
challenge that's smart he keeps it
looking like he's
still there it is true huh as well look
at that seal
mark zuckerberg sunder
yeah i mean he's uh the leader of uh
i think trump was just too much here's
the crazy things about trump man
i heard so before i would hear so many
stories about how trump would get
something built somewhere
and then like have and then never pay
the people
yeah yeah you would hear just so many
like
it's just dirty business i feel like he
was just a dirty business man i think he
had some good
intentions i don't think he was the guy
to be able to pull him off
here i think if he almost didn't
just didn't talk the whole time he'd
still be president he just sat
and just was like i think people you
know
the whole all the movement of people and
where they've already talked about
was just really powerful and just used
cnn like
every day they just talked about that
guy and they you know what they do now
so much money they don't know what they
don't do now they're just like can we
bring tubin back to yell at him more
they don't know who they ended up
too that they can't even really talk
about anything yeah you know
yeah i got rid of my cable i haven't
read my tv stuff
i did and then i got i think i'm gonna
get it back though yeah
that's nice yeah for sports yeah and one
of the fights this weekend
we got to get our thing going our next
fight now a comedy fight network
yeah the comedy fight network i would
love to see one other match up i think
on there
on the bill yeah we have we have eliza
versus
um craig fitzsimmons yeah i guess they
have to agree this too we have some
hurdles to overcome
yeah we got but we should probably do it
i don't think greg's right for eliza i
think there's a better someone like they
have a
beef that does someone she doesn't like
would be nice
okay so anyone yeah yes so anyway
great she got she got we got into a mask
thing a couple of weeks ago it was just
oh really i was like it was just
she does comedy correctly do you know me
by that she's got
she's got a down like the bells and
whistles of how to do it
and get a reaction she really is a very
good technical
comedic performer she knows the list you
know the lists at the end for a
standing ovation no i don't ever look at
that oh yeah you get like a
do you get if you want to standing
ovation i understand your show you just
get them yeah
or if they ever wayne what's that i mean
i'm not i shouldn't that's not right to
say
but i mean i put in the work i think i
just get them there's definitely ways
you know who said tell me george wallace
what is the list you know what it is
no it's just like it's a list joke where
it's like it doesn't give me any joke
i went to the starbucks all the mocha
dog frappuccino what's about you a long
list and then they give you a nice
applause you notice that she does she
does very
good technical stuff like that she knows
what she's doing she's she has some new
yeah
some new like it's like not
anti-christian but she's like your
angles
yeah she writes and then it's like yeah
so then it's like people are clap like
clapping
she could write a book on i don't think
we could write a book on comedy i think
she could write a book on comedy to make
uh people uh i think she has like
just thought it out dissected it
i don't know are you writing a comedy
book sorry no no i'm not i just don't
know about that um
yeah what else can we talk about dude
i'm trying to think of something really
interesting here's how about a
humiliating story
all right people like to hear uh
humiliating stories i find because then
they feel better about their life
yeah you've got plenty here's a guy this
is darren too
yo yo yo hopefully the interview is
going pretty good
if not you guys can answer this another
beard
what do you guys like to do outside of
comedy
in your free time what do you guys like
to do for fun
love to hear it hope you guys are doing
awesome
all right rock and roll
i like this guy i could hang out with
this guy he's
high as [ __ ] one eye is very high i
think he
has a shallow gape on that eye i don't
think he's fully eyed out
it's very red he's got great teeth a guy
who flosses
you know he's a good oh yeah
he's in a tub he's got a good fan going
his family's deceased in the next room
but
he's doing just he just murdered his
entire family
he's taking a bath this is his second
bat the first bat got the blood off now
this is his relaxed
bath to think about the murders yeah he
just might send some rupees to soul in a
few minutes but he can't decide if it's
too up tempo for the
for the time he did just buy some fans
from uh
from home to target yeah they're blowing
the other room
he said you have any loud fans i could
buy and i said right here sir
and they're helping uh after the blood
cleanup
nice marble backdrop he's doing well
he's just doing well
what was his question unless he bought a
piece of money what did we do behind the
tub just yeah
like the rest of the room is just a
cracked end but the corners nice
my spare time yeah what are you doing i
write music people don't know that i
write
classical music yeah you do not i'm
getting a piano right now yeah i gotta
yeah do you might get a young chang have
you ever oh
yeah wait is that what i have
i'm looking at young i rented mine i've
rented mine i think it might be a young
chang
wow i'm showing a picture of it yamaha
pearl river
uh what are some other ones i'm looking
at i love
i think mine's a young chang that's cool
do you play piano i mean i used to play
not well but i used to play yeah i
like young chang man yeah that's my big
hobby
i do uh that's you right there that's me
yeah wait there's more and then you
playing classical music
no my classical music is not i never
figured it out
i just like you know i gave my mom a
song you know
i'd have money for a gift so i wrote
things like that but um
i think i might do put an album out but
i don't think any like who'd want to
hear that
of classical music yeah i don't think
there's a big audience for that
i don't think there would be a huge
audience but big fans of yours would
like
to i would have it i think especially
even if it's
not even that great just light piano
songs in the background when you're
doing dishes or something i would love
that
that guy in the tub would actually be
nice if my songs were playing my little
piano songs
relaxing tub maybe i'll do relaxing tub
music
i'll be in a tub in the album cover i
miss album covers but
me too relaxing tub music is good yeah
kyle duncan's relaxing what do you do
for your free time what is your spare
time
i don't know man probably worry about
stuff oh that's right that's my number
one hobby actually never mind and i
don't even realize that sometimes i'm
like yeah
sometimes i'll catch myself doing it
what are you worried you seem not
worried about anything
yeah i'm getting less worried what else
the good thing about age is you do get
less worried just cool i just want the
energy for it
but i'll do i like to go do yoga i like
to go to the i like to do a little bit
of fitness
god you don't seem worried really if i
if you were to ask me
who's the one person who's least worried
that i know i would have said you
wow thanks yeah thanks a lot
that's good to hear man i feel like i'm
slowly getting less worried it's a
like things come to you you're you're
doing great
you you you tweet the n-word it seems
like a guy doesn't really care
that's true i will say this i do start
to feel a little bit more like
just willing to say what i want to say
recently i'm kind of tired of being
hammered up like
i'm doing like a netflix special in a
couple weeks that's one of the things
that's kept me like
scared i think a lot of times i'm trying
to be just say whatever i want
yeah and trying to write this animated
thing for netflix i just worry that
these corporations are going to have you
you're going to need them though i mean
you can you're off the grid i think you
you're you'll be okay financially even
if you don't have any netflix
things yeah that's true but you kind of
want it though but netflix is something
you kind of want that exposure sometimes
yeah but i don't even know if you need
it that much anymore yeah i don't have
it at all they're not interested
they have not called me well look in a
year they'll call and you won't even
want them dude that would be
the greatest thing my first netflix
special did nothing for me man oh really
absolutely like i remember i've told
this story but i went to chattanooga to
this show
it was this thick girl and i ended up
probably hooking up with her i don't
remember dude but thank god she was
there
you don't remember i didn't console me i
probably you think you think maybe you
did but you're not sure
i mean i probably could who knows who
knows what happened i did
but this is what happened i want time
i'm not i don't jump the story but i
don't know
who i hope this girl i was so drunk i
knew she was big in my head yeah
but i i sobered up the moment i looked
in the mirror we're in a bathroom
and i looked and i saw my hands were on
her pockets and i saw how far apart my
hands were wow they were like
three feet apart sexy yeah it was nice
anyway go ahead
god it's kind of so you're getting this
you know what the big the thing is about
kind of thicker women sometimes it
scares me i think
it's like i'm not gonna they're not
gonna get i'm not gonna be able to do
this
okay it's not like their body type i
don't like
yeah you're right yeah fear of inability
i also feel like are they attracted to
me i'm so tiny
right yeah i'm just a little giblet to
them yeah
like they must be like oh how am i going
to hold on to this how do i hug a pencil
yeah you would feel them kind of wrestle
you around and they've got control
yeah that can't be sexy for them yeah
like hey why don't you adjust my c-spine
while you're
so what happened with this girl um i
don't remember what happened what were
we talking about
you said chattanooga oh yeah so i went
to the show i had a netflix special came
out this is my first weekend
i get there nobody no way and this
special just came out yeah like 20
tickets wait did you have time what
about the show after that i mean did you
have time for them to
i did nothing it did nothing it was
heartbreaking damn
yeah i kind of want to do one just so i
could say i had one because i feel like
there's some kind of
like doing letterman or something meant
something now it's like doing
but yeah ultimately it'd be great not to
need someone else
mark norman's blew up on youtube it's
special yeah he did a smart thing
he just put it on youtube and it really
helped him out yeah
i i do think that that's the move i
think after this i mean
if this one goes through and we get it
out there
but i always worry about like man if i
say if i do if i do one thing is it
gonna cost me my special you know
even with mark's millions of views now
he's doing he's only doing the half hour
uh not only right good accomplishment
but he's on like the comics thing where
they give like
10 people half hour he that just
announced he has a half hour on netflix
coming oh okay
he probably got that i mean before oh
maybe i don't know how long it takes for
them to process you'd
know because if after this i think you'd
get a full one
after but how was your sales are your
tickets getting better
yeah my i cancelled my last trick as a
coved but
um the sales were pretty good but i
don't do you know
huge theaters i do like small like 300
seat or that's great though
i mean at somewhere because you go to
club i would go to clubs anyway it's
like it's
still it's awesome i have trouble also
satisfying that that thing
like some people will yell caitlyn or
something whatever i'll come out as
craig sometimes and it's just like
i'm jumping around and i want them to
enjoy the whole show
and it's like you know it's just a tough
thing but they enjoy
you i think that's one thing that i
don't even recognize at this point like
i didn't really realize until i sat in
the audience i watched brendan shaw
perform one night right
yeah and i watched him i sat there he
was performing in nashville so i went
and
and i sat in the crowd and people people
that are
fans they just want to be there with you
like
for me i'm always so high in my head
about the material i'm like
it's going to be okay for him and but
they just want to be
in the room with you it's almost like
they're saying it almost felt like the
fact because this is the vibe i got from
the fans around me who are watching him
that they were just happy they just want
to be in the room and having a good time
with you here's where you're wrong okay
you're right about you and brendan for
me i
don't really exist to most of the people
who are
who follow me and watch my stuff it's
like caitlyn
or biden or or craig it's like someone
else like
i'm i'm actually just starting to put
myself i'm gonna start putting more
videos of myself out because i think
that is the way to um make
more people happy is to have myself
involved as like a real person because
they're like i'm living and dying off is
this funny is this thing funny
right and i've always known there was a
stand up always felt i was living and
dying it's like
you're a personality people really enjoy
and i don't really have myself out there
as a personality i have like uh my
my comedy bits my you know impressions
or whatever
so it's not a hang for them to be with
me i don't think
you know i don't know i think you're
creative and so unique enough
that it for me i would be like i want to
just know more about who this person is
and so i think it's almost novel in the
way that
that's where they can get to know more
like who's behind this thing that i love
it's so powerful like also thompson
girls like that too or it's like
you guys are their friend and they want
to come and like have a party with you
guys that's very powerful and and great
and i am
i i i'm jealous of that i'd like to get
some of that did you ever do a pod or no
i did years ago but i also was kind of
side kicky i didn't
i didn't i wasn't the driver of it yeah
i would just kind of jump in with with
stuff
um but that did actually help my sense
to people's day
i would say ten percent of people come
to my shows are from that podcast so it
is more powerful to a podcast
in terms of getting people to your shows
and it's interesting and i find that
most people more
people that come up to me and say hey a
lot of times they're people that i would
like to know anyway
so it's like you kind of relate to
people that you would probably get along
with yeah yeah
yeah it's like you don't really get fans
you almost get like
if you had unlimited amount of time
people you would be friends with yeah
it's kind of interesting and you get to
talk the whole time which is great
in the relationship yeah that's kind of
nice that's kind of
it's a little bit hectic too what news
we got we got any news nick
yeah let's see uh the tyson fury fight
was postponed because he
tested positive for covid and so did
this camp oh
damn oh one other thing one last thing
about people we're just talking about
yeah
which i'm jealous of is creating content
like we've talked for
an hour and a half or something like we
can chat and have fun and just talk and
there's content that goes out you can
monetize it
what i make like to make a minute of
what i make
like i can't crank this i'm gonna try
but cranking
like seven minutes out a week is you
know there's a
whole tv shows doing trying to do that
yeah the all with all the staff and
everything
and it's really hard so doing a podcast
i need to do a podcast and so i can
because i think things seem to come out
every week
that's been my i think slowing me down
as i will take a month break and
uh well you can't burn yourself out also
yeah that's a lot of work that you do
especially if you're doing the editing
this buying thing no joke took me about
300 hours it took me
six weeks to do 20 minutes of this this
is so good
yeah you're making like a i wonder but
the good thing is it sounds like if now
if you've got some ad revenue starts to
come in maybe you can hire somebody who
could you think you could hire somebody
to do the edit or is it that
close to you it's funny i've had a
couple people edit but it's like
you know with comedy timing is a lot he
has to be a
really good timing because then you have
to go back and adjust little things
but i need to loosen the range a little
bit and let someone else um
ig clips and different things i'll be
like what about you know because you
know the timing you know what it is
you want it to be what you imagined and
then like i'm doing the lighting and
there's no
director so then i'll do a whole i'll
shoot for like a half hour then realize
like my ear was out of the hat wrong i
have to go redo it like there's no one
you know you're on a set there's so many
people you're like telling you why is
all these people here they all need to
be there
yeah anyway i've discovered that it is
pretty fascinating you do realize like
you're doing it at a lower budget thing
or at like a lower level that
you realize what everybody's for the the
the amount of time
i i have to like deal with wigs it's
like disturbing
that's beautiful this is beautiful
it is kind of beautiful um here we go
what we got here that's just him talking
about corn pop
oh yeah he's core pocket he's a bad dude
come on man i learned
that uh it makes a difference this was
the driving board area
and i was one of the guards and they
weren't allowed it was a three meter
board
and you fell off sideways you landed on
the dams uh the darn cement
over there and corn pop was a bad
dude and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed
one of the things you had to use if you
use pomade in your hair you had to wear
a bathing cap
and so he was up on the board one
listening i said hey esther
you off the board i'll come up and drag
you off
he didn't say he came off and he said
i'll meet you outside my car this
was mostly these were all public housing
behind it
my car there was a gate out here i
parked my car outside the gate
and i he said i'll be waiting for you
he's waiting for three guys in straight
razors
not a joke there's a guy named bill
wright mouse
the only white guy and he did all the
pools he was the mechanic
and i said what am i going to do he said
come down here in the basement
where mechanics where where all the pool
filter is you know the chain used to be
a chain that went across
the deep end and he cut off a six foot
length of chain he pulled up he said you
walk out
with that chain and you walk to the car
and say you may cut me man but i'm going
to wrap this chain around your head
i said you're kidding me he said no if
you don't don't come back and he was
right
so i walked out with the chain and i
walked up to my car
and they had those days usually
you know
and i looked at him but i was smart
physically forced to stand there
i said when i tell you get off the board
you get off the board i'll kick you out
again but i shouldn't have called you
esther williams i apologize for that
i apologize is this corn pop i apologize
gonna work
he said you apologize to me i said i
apologize but i'm not for throwing you
out
but i apologize for what i said he said
okay
close the straight razor my heart began
to beat again
that's some laughs long story though she
was a uh
female swimmer in like the 50s that's
our present
and that's when you're doing well not
the not not this sonic
yeah he was a bad dude man he was a bad
dude man
hey corn pop i got chain wrapped around
my face yeah
yeah not not in my face corn pop not my
favorite
my
you feel this whole team is probably
just like their butthole's just
clenching as that story went on
how long is it gonna i mean he's
deteriorating
i don't think he's gonna do a second
term second term i
don't see how we can do another year i
don't i i don't really like
you know i grew up with a seat with a
senior citizen father i just
it goes pretty quick i feel like it's
going right
yeah i do too i feel like it's not a
joke is it
i mean i remember when reagan towards
the end they were
they hit it like we won't be told about
it
reagan was someone was talking about he
was in the plane he's like
they look like little ants down there he
was having to deal with some major
issue with iran or something and he just
was talking about ants
nancy reagan this was like right after
he was just got out of office he came
home and he would go to a different
office just to be in an office he'd come
home he came home his hand was all wet
and she's like what's in your hand and
he opened up it was from the fish tank
it was a white house a mini white house
with a fish to swim around next to
and he said this has something to do
with me
there's a fish now the white house in
his hand
oh a little one a little white house
from like the fish tank
and this is like get out of the bottom
he took it out of the fish tank it was
like this has something to do with it
he was like just at office oh wow scary
anyway
almost like everything's fine yeah like
deadliest catch kind of
exactly like that wow
um would that guy want to know oh that
was joe biden sorry
what was his question though i thought
that was a question we actually didn't
play a question
another
mostly bearded i you know what i did
notice the most
blue-eyed fans i'd ever seen were in
ohio
interesting you have a little facial
hair i wonder if they're copying it
they're like part of your team
that's like the sign no i can ideally
actually have a choke
that's an amazing really thick beard he
has
this man has beautiful hair i would i
can put that on the top
i worry about the top because of the
do-rag i worry that there's
no yeah i think this guy has a lot he's
got that joey fatone
gene patone vibes
i got a question from mr cow den again
guy i was curious
what's the what's with the voice is that
just a natural-born talent that you can
match your voice to them all them
people's voices
when you're doing impersonations or is
that something that you learn you can
change your voice like you have the
voice of a chameleon
something like that anyway there you go
me and my brother tilting come to this
yeah
here in a rich man oh little tilton
coming up beautiful
bring his little ass out gang daddy
thank you yeah do you think you created
the voices because did you do it when
you were little what did you do
yeah yeah i would do like uh you know my
teachers and stuff like that yeah
uh would you rate at recess and stuff
yeah i remember i did a talent show i
did some of the
voices of the teacher one time i got
woman to high school
did a talent show and uh someone was
like
my friend's like you should just stand
up there's another example of someone
just telling me what to do and i did it
i look back and i like i
know and i still struggle i had no
impetus to be like i want to do this
i was just told you should just stand up
20 minutes before the show started
you know you can't do that yeah so
anyway i i just did like impressions of
the teacher but i got suspended
and dragged off the stage it was my
first stand-up show
because i did do like some stand-up
about it wasn't even that dirty but the
guy before me got suspended so there was
suspend happy
ah i said like something about a cog
that's one by like you know kids talk
about
and then the [ __ ] you said yeah [ __ ] or
something about dicks
that's cool and the host this girl my
age came up she whispered in the middle
of the show she goes
you can't say that miss all that's going
to suspend you it
stopped the whole show dad and then i
was like
i'm not allowed to say penis anymore and
i started saying other thing and then
they
must drag me off anyway what was my
point um yeah
i did uh i i um yeah
i think um i think part of it's like i
have a long neck
i can i can move my vocal chords really
far and stretch them
i think part of it i think the other
part is um like musically
i think if you have a good ear with like
tones you can kind of match people like
that
yeah and uh yeah that makes sense man if
you can do the piano
oh and then you can play yourself i was
also very disappearing kind of child
like i
like craig that character i've been
doing that since i was
probably seven years old i have pictures
of me doing that because
it was when my mother would listen to
these other characters this is
working a deep podcast but like she
would listen
she wouldn't listen to me but when i was
someone else she would listen so i ended
up
i think that pushed me he would talk
about free will i think that also pushed
me a little bit into
i could totally see that like creating
fine in some way to be heard
and to not be yourself do something yeah
yeah i think i got attention
from like kids you have to michael
jackson that was a big one when i was
younger i love this girl who loved
michael jackson she had
michael jackson written on her shoes and
i would do michael jackson first my way
to talk to her
really that's that that that's i just
realized that that was probably huge
for me to like doing impressions you
would just go up to her and do it
or whatever
she scraped michael jackson off her shoe
and i was devastated like i felt like it
was me she was scraping away
we were remember the first time i ever
touched a boo went to the movies right
and this girl was
jacked my first girlfriend was a [ __ ]
second base on the baseball team i think
oh really
jack and that makes the boobs look
smaller when she's got big shoulders
right it's a tight boob dude
it could have been a guy it could have
been a guy named susannah
she's beautiful grew up to be a
beautiful lady but uh
at the time she just had these hard
[ __ ] ripping tits
and that was your first experience with
boobs yeah do you like them like that
because it was your first
sometimes that wakes up here now i
remember one time i met this lady in
in uh north carolina and she had
breastfeed they were like malleable
like you could shape them into like a
and they would stay the diaper yeah and
they would stand no way there's
something wrong with that
it blew my mind
and it was so scary being in her place
because i felt like i was on drugs some
i think i've probably been drinking or
maybe had a little bit of weight that
might have been a breast implant that
was bad
it could have been a bad yeah yeah
that's definitely what it was i think
yeah it's not gonna have been uh you
know
some heavy play-doh in there or
something but it was uh
yammer you could shape it and it would
stay that way yeah you can go to mexico
and get some weird stuff put in
those lava lamp tits where they kind of
move up and down
yeah yeah it's crazy and glow um
but anyway what was that question there
wasn't one oh
you just leaned over and slid it in
we're making out at the movies man oh i
just got a flash of something yeah
making out at the movies yeah and i
just she had a button up she wore a lot
of button ups okay kind of unique for a
young woman but
a lot of butt professional yeah yeah she
was a pro
so you leaned did you unbutton you just
slide in between
and she let you and i tried to go up the
bottom but the butt the buttons
wearing pants the texture uh cut my the
the tautness from where the buttons and
the shirt cut my ability to reach
up so they had to go in through them you
must be like look at this guy's trying
to sneak in
they have so much time to just judge us
oh yeah we're making out
hot and heavy dudes yeah god we were
[ __ ] this is your first boob
oh and you reached down strong well
actually the first breaths ever touched
but it was more
child we were more real real child real
children
this girl they had an electric fence
girl let me feel her head through it
do the electric fence yeah oh wow that's
kind of
you might be into kinky [ __ ] that's your
first experience it was scary man it was
hard and it was risky and i think it
always made me really nervous after that
because it was like
boy that's linked up with sexuality and
risk because you could barely like i had
to like barely kind of get my fingers
over there and she had her boob out or
just was
over shirt she had like a little sun
dress kind of on
so it was over 009 okay young so it
wasn't a tit yet i mean it was
it was a you know it's still you still
liked it yeah i remember seeing down a
girl's shirt when i was like
seven she was like six and i thought it
was hot somehow at that age i don't know
how
i was like i'm seeing something i wasn't
supposed to oh yeah but there was
nothing there
i was i used we used to watch the movies
like with friends i had like pretty hot
friends in
in high school it's called leslie gerard
put my arm around her
yeah i wasn't dating her i never had a
guts to like make a move or anything i'm
armored watching a movie
and i i remember like pushing down on
her top boob
here and that was so hot to me
he imagined that being like because it
was still boobs yeah even though it was
like
it's like far away from the nipple but
it was like it was mushy
still counts oh man it's so so
disturbing to be a guy
somebody needs to answer that clown
phone
i think this thing is ringing off it's
available yeah
i should still have that um man well
we learned a lot today whatever you do
kyle you just have to keep going man we
just need you in the world thank you too
so entertaining to watch bro i love it i
really do feel like i'm doing what i
like to do
that's awesome the only thing is i'm
exhausted but i'm happy that's fine
i don't have a social life at all you
don't really don't man a girl comes
past weekend like she stayed for the
weekend disaster where'd she go
england what she lives here but she came
back early
she was working in england like her
thing got postponed to the covey but she
flew in
it was really yeah it didn't it was what
was it a disaster
it was so much drama dude i i was
really like my best self yeah you know i
wasn't even me i was like this
prince who'd hold door opens get you
what you want
and i told her before she came i was
like i i have to work i have this
thing i'm making i don't feel ignored i
learned that like
this girl's like you didn't tell me i
was like don't come if you're gonna feel
ignored i've gotta work and she's like
oh
i've got plenty to do so the first few
days i took off which i couldn't even
afford but i really did like her and it
was going well
and then the third day right when i
started working it was like
i mean she was crying on the couch she
was like she was in the dark at one
point just like sitting in the dark
and i'm like japanese
i see why you asked that but no yeah but
i would like be
rushing to work because i i just did
till four in the morning she knew i was
getting like an hour sleep and still she
couldn't
some people can't not have attention it
really is disturbing
and i do like the free will that i don't
think she could help it it was just very
uncomfortable for her for me to work
we're such creatures of discomfort it's
a lot of life is balancing your
discomfort really yeah or hiding it
you're going pleasure pain you're going
like how much pleasure could be to how
much
pain and then you'd make your
subconscious makes a decision that's
going back to free will and then you
think you thought it and you didn't
see that's the part i don't know because
i think there's some free willies out
there man
it feels like it but no that's just the
trick that's the trick
leslie uh nikki glazier was in here
talking about that
oh yeah she loves sam harris yeah she
loves it and so i got i'll investigate
and
see if i can get some feedback for you i
would like to hear your thoughts on it
because i also
don't want to i don't want to believe it
i don't believe disturbed by it
yeah i had to put the book down like
they did like scientific experiments
where they know
which arm the pers which hand they're
going to raise before the person knows
it
and what is that for pledge of
allegiance
now just experiment oh yeah i don't know
i would always i i usually get the wrong
one and then do the right one
yeah and then they also found people
make up why they decided it
and the experiment is no it's it's
pretty freaky freaky stuff going on guys
you are a robot you can audiobook you
can you know download it it's not long
i don't know there's some things it's
like why do we allow them to exist it's
like
it's like it's no fun you're right it's
no fun right and having no heaven
i hate not having a heaven although i'll
tell you one thing about not having a
heaven it does make you wake up here
like if this is
it it's almost a crime to not realize
this is it i gotta get busy yeah
you know we've done dmt have you tried
dmt yet no i'm scared
i want i'm too scared if you try it then
you see what happens when you die so
i i'm terrified you'll be fine uh
you might not i feel like i'm mentally
not you might not
yeah you might want to stay where you
are you're doing good where you are you
might
we need you in this realm okay kyle
dunnigan uh ladies and gentlemen you can
check out craig's news live you can
check out
uh the fresh prince of dc youtube's the
place to go i'm done with instagram
there's no money
and you could you can find theo here in
a bunch of places
do some other podcasts i would love to
do more yeah this has been a great chat
and also our i think our fight idea is
not something that should die
here this should be something we talk
about yeah maybe in the comments you
guys could put other bouts that might be
good who would you like to see i would
love to see bobby lee this
doesn't have the physical acumen anymore
he wouldn't do it
and his body's fading fast i remember we
can't have someone drop dead that's be
the worst thing yeah they don't have to
be comedians maybe we just start like
our own
fight club that's like funnier or it's
more like
because these things are no fun you know
you see lamar odom and what's his name
fight that kid
nick carter aaron carter we could
probably just contact these people and
be like here's a hundred thousand
dollars
you know these fans want to see it
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money for like
someone like who was on save by the bell
or something and want some money like
elizabeth
dustin diamond but elizabeth's still
alive but
yeah they said aaron carter and lamar
odom just be i mean this was insane bro
wait who aaron carter's nuts who's
wait a minute the reach is insane
oh he's six feet he's not that short but
jesus has an 11
inch reach advantage i worry about
lamar's heart to be honest
when did this happen how did i miss this
lamar does have coke but it was like two
weeks ago no one knew
it's no one knew how many views does
this have
let's see this look at this little twerp
he's six feet
[Applause]
oh my god he's throwing bombs oh it's
one little flick
that did nothing to lamar though huh i
don't know lamar is that [ __ ] coke
dude i bet it did
now he's now i started getting real now
it's over this is a hate crime
he's six feet tall that's a hate crime
he's seven feet who's six feet aaron
that's what it says
aaron looks like he's he is six feet he
looks five feet tall there
now he's just on the run oh my god he's
got an answer to that
he's got the low pants even with on the
fight see that's the uh
who's who's hotter you think out of
these two guys no homo
lamar or aaron harder that's tough it
depends what they're doing to me am i
am i doing something to them or am i
receiving both you guys you're not even
around them it's just
yeah this isn't a date dude it's just
like you see them somewhere
or just they're both they're swimming i
mean you're talking about are their
head gears blocking their face but i
would body wise
no just i'm not talking about them
overall
who's hotter out of these two man who's
hotter and i don't care who is
wait wait is there more fighting i hope
that it that was it
they ended early i thought lamar's had
her i mean he guessed he destroyed it
but we could have something like that
yeah we host it
would i host it we hosted it you and i
got to know you and you'll host the
fight
um they were big they a big head gear
like it's still funny then they won't
get hurt and it's still funny to
who would we get to fight we could have
the the fans we could just ask what they
want to say because
there's a lot of people like b
celebrities that you don't see anymore
but
you know someone who's on full house or
something that they need money right now
you give them money
they go in the ring we get 90 just
kidding
and then kimmy gabler versus like
elton john's son yeah magic johnson's
son
i think the audience will come up with
some really creative people
sending videos to tpw with your
suggestions yeah because if they come up
with
because we could call this person up or
dm then be like look you want 100 grand
right but how do we make the money so we
can pay them we do the we do a live show
we get we rent out a little area for the
ring we
rent a ring that'd be easy to do it'd be
easy
but say then how do people buy it they
buy it on pay-per-view so we advertise
we could do one of those live shows
things like they do we advertise okay so
let's say for example we sell
ten thousand tickets right to the live
boxing fifty thousand yeah
okay if you think we can our two
audiences okay say we sell
25 000 tickets i just want to be safe
yeah okay ten dollars a pop
okay i think you can probably you
probably have more you can get probably
15 people fighting
their fame that they're they're beloved
characters from tb
you're gonna make 300 grand then so
you're gonna have to pay a hundred grand
to the fighters mm-hmm so that's 50 each
for the two fighters
you can make 200 you're going to owe
probably 10 percent to the
you can probably have 10 in charges in
like venue and insurance
so then you're down to
120 and then we got to pay 12 musical
acts
that's true we have to get a musical act
to perform too i can get one so cheap
that's amazing but also now look at this
we need more fights that's only one
fight we need three fights
well the undercards are gonna get it's
just gonna be for fun they're gonna get
a few couple of grand and maybe the the
the the
they get 30 grand each i don't think you
even need to pay them that
i really it's fun
they'll have a headgear on it's but i
would do it dude anyone cared
i jump in the ring on local fights the
undercard fighters usually they get like
a
200 but then they get like what about
down and outs
someone who's like needs [ __ ] money
who are you talking about somebody in a
coma
no someone who's just like their wife
took all their [ __ ] some story we built
this guy needs a
this guy needs five grand yeah and then
we show the clip of him like
[ __ ] my wife that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
and then maybe it's the guy who cheated
on his wife with him we could give up a
nice little story he's like hey i'm
randall
yeah i [ __ ] his wife i don't care i'll
beat him his ass too yeah i've been
[ __ ] her and i've been hitting her
i could edit that package yeah
dude that's okay now you're talking and
we built it up we can really
put those videos on our whatever yeah
clips
get a picture you know yeah yeah yeah
i hammered his wife and i'm going to
look into him yeah yeah yeah
yeah colin theo's boxing down and out
down and out boxing
blowout and then there's a prize i don't
know
there's some nudity yeah any nude card
girls
and men and men dude men and women card
girls
and boys they just come out with a dick
so you get children
no we do it in a uh international
journalism
and it's new children
this is why we workshop now yeah yeah we
got we got more to talk about but
something like that okay
okay we're on to a good idea guys you
can follow find kyle dunham
we'll put his links to his youtube
channel actually we'll put it at the
first loop
the first link to this video is to
kyle's youtube channel please go and
subscribe to it so you can see them yeah
please like let's get that algorithm
let's let's look at allen
yeah you want to see us oh you want to
have sex again all right
[Music]
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself unwind
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy
[Music]
[Music]
now